as a fan of the franchise i don't think
anybody was certain or expected to get
another film what was it like for you to
when you got the phone call that neo and
trinity were coming back how exciting
was that
it was uh that's a special day um
yeah it was it came out of the blue and
uh
it was uh
it was uh quite shocking
but uh it was very exciting and so happy
that lana wachowski called me
and was really
excited to start
the journey i've heard keanu say it's
the kind of call that he had to stand up
for me it was the kind of call i had to
sit down so
[Laughter]
just like
yeah it was it was
mind-altering
for
sure have we met
since the original film 20 plus years
how has your relationship evolved and
and how much has it aided in us getting
to see this beautiful love story on
screen
yeah i mean i think i mean i would say
it stayed more consistent more the same
than it has changed
it's uh
the eternal
neo-trinity love
yeah i felt super comfortable to start
working together again and to
partner up and i was
so happy we were there
and to share it with you and
yeah felt really good yeah i always felt
when the first movie came out it was so
ahead of its time cinematically as far
as stories being told what we were
seeing on the screen how do you think
the movie helped shape and evolve to
future movies that came after it
i agree sir
no it did i mean certainly if we look at
bullet time cinematically
was influential i think the influences
that went into the matrix brought those
influences to
other filmmakers in terms of anime
camera angles action started training
actors
and actresses to try and do more
physical acting i think the humor is
tough to do to make such an entertaining
kind of science fiction film that's you
know also about philosophy and big ideas
um yeah
that's my riff
i know kung fu i think that we you know
we definitely saw a lot of
some of the things that we did in the
movie kind of move into commercials and
i mean it was sort of everywhere right
um
but
it also let people start doing films
that were about
you know reality and artificial reality
and what is reality
and one could almost say that it helped
kind of transition into
american acceptance of horror films
maybe in a different way if we wanted to
go into it
um
just riffing again but did it change
your guys take on reality like you just
said i always was so intrigued by the
examining and dissecting of life and
what it really is and are we in this or
is this something else did it change
your perspective as far as actors and
humans looking at the world yes
yeah it still is yeah i mean i which i
think is great i mean i think that's
important for us and hopefully the
audience can you know in an entertaining
way take that on board and
um you know i think you know the at the
ground of these films is this
idea of compassion and love
for all sentient beings you know and you
know we see it in the films with
artificial intelligence programs
machines what was the future
in 1999 and 2003 is
our present and i think the film also
propels us into the future that were
you know that is coming towards us and
maybe another way to examine what's
going on around us and who we are in it
i still know kung fu
you